When you think of “dependence” and “relapse”
you’re probably more likely to think of
heroin than marijuana.
But could weed be addictive?
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Nearly half the country has legalized medical
marijuana, and with more people using it,
there are more concerns about potential health
effects.
Amongst those health effects is...addiction.
A scary word, but a public health problem
that comes with many drugs and mind-altering
substances.
A new study released in the Journal of Addiction
Medicine has found that yes, marijuana can
be addicting.
The study included 127 adolescents who were
undergoing outpatient treatment for substance
abuse - and for most of them, marijuana was
their drug of choice.
Out of those who used marijuana, 84% of them
qualified as having “marijuana dependence”,
which the researchers defined as increased
use of marijuana, increased tolerance of marijuana,
and unsuccessful attempts to stop using it.
40% also experienced symptoms of withdrawal
when they stopped, and were more likely to
have problems at school, work, or home.
Those symptoms looked much like other drugs
in a state of withdrawal: anxiety, irritability,
trouble sleeping, and depression.
Interestingly, this group experiencing symptoms
were also more likely to have symptoms of
mood disorders.
They evaluated all the data based on self
reports right away and at 3, 6, and 12 months
later.
It’s an interesting study, but some of the
data from the report has me confused.
For instance, while increased usage of marijuana
could mean addiction, that isn’t necessarily
a defining characteristic.
And if those experiencing withdrawal have
symptoms of mood disorders, where does the
possibility of an previously existing disorder
come into play?
Fortunately this isn’t the only data we
have -- there are other studies this is building
on.
A 1999 report from the Institute of Medicine
also found signs of marijuana dependence in
about 9% of users.
Past studies have also demonstrated physical
and psychological withdrawal symptoms in both
people and animals.
Firing back at the new release, the National
Organization for the Reform of Marijuana Laws
has stated that while a small percentage may
suffer drug dependence at some point in their
lifetime, it’s the context of a person’s
life that matters.
They also said that withdrawal from marijuana
is relatively short-lived, and that it should
not be regulated as a Schedule I drug on par
with heroin.
Health advocates at Brown University state
that no one would argue that marijuana is
as addictive as alcohol or cocaine...but we’re
finding marijuana has addictive properties
for some people.
And the idea that marijuana can’t be addictive
makes it harder for those who are affected
to get help and support.
Let me know what you think about the addiction
debate down below and we’ll see you next
time here on DNews.